all right excellent all right hello
everybody I'm so excited to see so many
people here at the end of the day and
I'm really excited to be here talking to
you about enterprise ops particular
managing your business on gcp and beyond
now i know i am the last thing between
you and tasty beverages so i'm going to
get to the point and my hope is that if
there's one thing that you take away
from this presentation is that we have
you covered either natively on gcp or
through our growing ecosystem of
partners to help you address your
enterprise ops needs in particular
automation governance risk compliance so
this is a high-level agenda of what I'm
going to talk about the first you know
the first half of the the session I'm
going to be focusing primarily on what
we're doing on gcp and then I'm going to
turn it over to our partners who we
announced today Splunk and BMC and
they're going to come on stage and
demonstrate some of their integrations
and tell you a little bit more about the
applications and what you can do with
that so broadly I'm going to talk a
little bit about some of the management
tools that are available to you dive a
little bit into automation governance
risk and compliance and then I'm going
to dive a little bit deeper into cloud
audit logs which is a new service that
we're launching and I'm really quite
excited about so intuitive intelligent
management one of the great things about
the cloud platform is that you don't
have to work with multiple systems that
don't talk to each other you don't have
to deal with multiple vendors of wide
variety of systems to provision
resources if you want to you know
generate a new vm if you want to get new
new storage if you want to change your
networking they can all be done from
within the same place you can do it you
can easily provision resources with a
single click and more importantly easy
d provision them so you no longer have
to deal with that world we're adding new
resources requires a p.o it's really
just a single click we also want to
ensure that you can manage your
environment your way and what does that
mean what we know is that there are lots
of different people who are managing
these environments and you have
different preferences for how you're
going to want to work with this many of
you may want to come to this and work
with a web UI like I demonstrated on the
last page our cloud console but many of
you are going to want to interact with
it through an API or through the command
line interface and so we make sure that
all of our services expose their
capabilities through a REST API through
a command-line interface as well as that
cloud console now when problems happen
and as they always do they often happen
when you're not in front of your desktop
and so to complement that to help deal
with that situation we provide a mobile
management and monitoring tools so you
can download this mobile cloud console
for Android or iOS and it allows you to
look and see your environment so you can
see you can do the network monitoring
you can look at logs if you want to
interact with individual resources you
can do that as well for instance you can
look and see this VM is causing you
problems and you can stop it delete it
and if you really want to connect to it
via SSH on your phone you can do that
too so now I give you a little that was
really just kind of a highlight overview
of some of the management tools that are
available to you I'm going to touch
briefly now on automation governance
risk compliance and the first area I
want to focus on is automation now you
probably heard a lot about this in the
keynote this morning how Google's really
been very active with containers for a
long time and have built out great tools
for managing that and that has enabled
us to grow our infrastructure in our
workloads much faster than we've been
able then we've needed to grow our ops
team to support that and with that based
on that experience we developed kuber
Nettie's which is an open-source
container orchestration system
and we've made it available it's
governed by an independent foundation is
enjoying broad industry support
importantly we're embracing the concept
of multi-cloud as well as on-prem p.m.
bare metal so you can use Cooper
Nettie's in all these situations and to
make it easier for you particularly when
working with gcp we provide container
engine which is a fully managed and
hosted coo burnetii system and that
allows you to very easily create and
deploy clusters with a single click now
I'm not going to talk too much more
about this because you've probably heard
a little bit about at the keynote but
there's also a great talk tomorrow at
11am going into much more detail about
container engine so I would encourage
you to go to that one thing that we know
is that you know as companies are moving
to the cloud you're often either coming
from on-prem or you're in a multi cloud
environment which means you're already
using tools for IT automation and
there's a large number of open source
tools out there that people are using
and we want you to be able to continue
to use the tools that you're comfortable
with as you come to the cloud so we have
a lot of you know we encourage our
engineers to participate in these open
source projects and to contribute to
them to ensure that all these tools work
just as well on gcp or to ensure that
you can add gcp support to them now
governance i'm going to this is going to
be quick because not because it's not
important because i know governance is
really important in one of our you know
top feature requests is around identity
and access management but there's a
whole talk tomorrow at two fifteen
solely focused on identity and access
management talking about the
capabilities that we have there and so I
would really encourage you to attend
that talk as well and now lastly in this
section risk and compliance this is an
area that I know is incredibly important
to enterprises and large organizations
and every year we participate in
independent audits of our infrastructure
our services are different operations
and the goal here is to be comprehensive
and to provide assurance
is of the information security to help
you with your do yeah to help you feel
comfortable with this and to meet your
security and compliance needs so you can
see we've met a number of cloud platform
certifications as a result of that we're
also able to sign business associate
agreements if you're working in a HIPAA
regulated environment and then thinking
more about data security and privacy
just descent just this past December we
launched EU model contract clauses to
help you with managing your EU data one
of the important things when you're
thinking about risk and compliance
though is it's great and very important
that the platform has these
certifications so that you can feel
comfortable with the platform that
you're using but it's also really
important for you to be able to know
what you're doing on the platform
because that plays a major role there as
well and this ties in nicely to my next
topic which a cloud audit logs so this
is a new service that we're providing to
allow you to understand who did what
where and when on Google cloud platform
and it's built on the same proven and
scalable infrastructure that powers all
of our other cloud logging services and
what's nice about this is that the
events that are captured in these logs
they're available to you in the cloud
console as was demonstrated in the
keynote this morning as well alongside
all the other logs and stack driver
which you probably saw as well and this
requires no configuration on your part
they're just there they're available to
you and there's actually been really you
know embraced by a lot of our early
customers who've been using this this
quote from snapchat from subash me says
snapchat handle sensitive user data in a
trust Google cloud platform with the
storage cloud audit logging provides us
with the ability to monitor this data
across a variety of resources types in
near real-time and for our teams to take
timely action if needed so that's
meeting our goals this is what we want
you to be able to do so I want to talk a
little bit more about the audit logs
themselves because this is important to
understand they're actually two
different type of audit logs the first
one is the admin activity log and this
captures every
user action or API method that modifies
the configuration or metadata of a
service or a project so for instance
when you set the IAM policy if you
create a new project if you deploy a new
app engine application all of those get
captured here those are actions that
you're taking that you know make a
change to the service of the project and
these are always on for every project no
work required on your part they're just
available and this is true for all the
services that have completed their
integration with the App Engine
infrastructure the audit logging
infrastructure and I say they're no
exemptions and that means basically you
know they're you know everything that
you do get slaw all of these actions get
logged now the data access log is a
little bit different this is where we
capture all of your interactions whether
they're modifications or just reads with
user data that's provided a user
provided data that's managed by the
service so as an example of this with
bigquery when you import data to a table
and bigquery or if you export data from
bigquery or if you do a query with in
bigquery all of these get captured in
the data access log and we've broken
them out into two different logs because
they have different use cases and also
the data access log tends to be a lot
higher volume than the admin activity
log so we don't want there to be one to
flood the other out i would say these
are generally you know the model for
these are there mostly opt in for the
data access logs you would have to
explicitly turn it on although right now
the bigquery audit logs are on by
default for everybody because there's
been such positive feedback about the
value that they have in understanding
your utilization of bigquery and there's
one last point here so I had said with
the admin activity logs there were no
exemptions but with the data access logs
we are we do have the capability for you
to exempt certain service accounts from
data access logging now this isn't a
self-serve process at the moment but the
idea here is that you really want to
understand you know when your users are
looking at data not necessarily when
you're
you know hike ups application is
querying the data so if you have a known
trusted application running as a service
account you can tell us that and we will
exempt that from the logging as I said
going back to governance there were you
know we're introducing I am we have
there a number of access roles that are
relevant here there's the logs reader
role which grants you access to the
admin activity logs does the private
logs reader role and this is a separate
permission that grants you access to the
data access logs independent of the
admin activity logs and we do this
because the data access logs contains
information about your access to user
provided data so we you know often
there's a different level of sensitivity
about who gets to see those logs there's
also a config writer role which allows
you to change the or configure the
export settings with the logging system
and that you may not want to have the
person who is interacting with those
logs also being able to change that and
then lastly there's this logs rider role
which I put up here because it's
actually not relevant to audit logs
because audit logs are special with
respect to the other type of logs that
we collect and that they're immutable
and nobody can write to them except for
Google services so App Engine can write
to these but you as a user can't call
the logging API and put logs into the
audit log streams so where do we stand
right now this is where we are with
admin activity logs we have a number of
services in beta they'll be launching to
GA soon and we have a large number of
other services coming soon in the in the
next couple months in the coming soon
means they're either in private alpha
with a number of early users or will be
be so shortly data access logs bigquery
is already providing data access logs
for everybody if you haven't seen them
they're there and cloud sequel and cloud
storage will be following soon so now
I'm going to change gears and let me
just and do a quick demonstration let me
just log in to show you to show you the
audit logs in action so what you can see
here is as was demonstrated earlier in
the keynote today is the activity stream
and you can see the different
interactions
that have happened inside this project
so if you look down here at the bottom
you can see i created this project i
created an application within the
project get some of the details there I
you know I set the I am policy and you
can see how I set that and you can
scroll further up and see you know we
created a we created some data sets to
hold table to hold data in bigquery and
so there's a wide variety of
interactions that you can see what's
nice about the activity stream is you
can also look at data from multiple
projects simultaneously so I have
another project here and you can see
what you know we're very active with I
am earlier today but you can see the you
know you've got you know the audit log
demo here Enterprise ops demo you can
see them you know in between you know
interleave together relatively easily
now one thing that you could not do
prior to today was look at your data
access logs inside the Activity Stream
you can now do that so I'm going to
click on data access logs and you can
now see all my data access log activity
here so I can look at you know the
queries I was making but what's nice is
actually though you scroll down here and
you see these ones with the the ! there
and that tells you that it was actually
a failed action so we not only do we
capture all the successful API actions
we capture all the failures and when you
know if we will capture it if it failed
because it didn't work but will also
capture it because you were denied
access and this is an example where my
colleague here he was trying he was
looking we pulled in this HR database
and he was trying to join the employee
IDs with the compensation and he didn't
have access to the compensation database
and so he was denied that was not able
to see those there and now I want to
talk quickly about the fact that as we
said earlier the audit logs are
available to you in activity stream but
we also have this nice tight integration
with stackdriver so you can look at all
of your logs in inside the stack driver
logs viewer just like you could anywhere
else and you can see the different
resources you can see the different log
types you can expand the nicely
structured logs here
I've actually filtered this by using the
the text filters so I was looking for
all the job service to insert operations
but you know I can also filter this by
you know if I want to see you know what
did i do you know what are the actions
that I performed I can filter those
there as well by virtue of this
integration you can also take advantage
of the export capabilities so I can
export these logs for long term archival
and storage to cloud storage I can also
export them to bigquery which is
actually very valuable because it gives
you additional types of insight and i'm
going to show you that right here so one
thing here is so i'm actually going to
look at use bigquery to look at the
bigquery audit logs because what you can
do now is you can gain more insight and
get kind of you know a rough estimate of
your utilization and how that translates
into your spend so we've created this
query here you know 7-day spend going to
run the query and it just takes a second
to operate over that and it sees that
you know over the past five days it
looks like i have spent five cents on
bigquery so go me for not spending a lot
of money but you know i just didn't have
a lot of time to play with this but
what's nice about this is that because
these are the audit logs we're also
capturing the information around who's
doing this so if i want to find out you
know so yes we found out that you know
five cents was spent on this i can do it
can instead run this by you know query
by user and it'll break it out and you
can see that you know I you know my work
account was responsible for four cents I
use my personal account as a way in to
check it out and that was worth one cent
and my colleague ahmer he actually
didn't rack up any money because he kept
getting denied and so you can see that
it's just it's a great use of the
bigquery to look at bigquery zone logs
and now if I go back to the logs viewer
we can actually see you know these are
the you know the fresh entries that I
was just those are different ones so if
I would go back to like job service to
insert
and you can see that you know these were
the logs that I just triggered a moment
ago so and then so just coming quickly
back to exports the one export I didn't
touch on already was our ability to
export the pub so and this gives you the
ability to publish your logs to pub/sub
where anybody listening to those but you
know you've granted access to can then
do further processing on the logs so if
you want to have data flow jobs
listening to that and processing your
logs you can do that but it also means
we can partner with a variety of third
parties who can also listen on these and
that way it allows you to push your logs
to a variety of our partners can we
switch back to my slides thank you so as
we as we may have heard we're announcing
a number of partnerships today in
particular splunk antenna bowl we've
partnered with to send logs out of
stackdriver logging to their systems log
entries was a partner beforehand and at
this point I'd like to invite Martian a
from splunk to come up on stage and tell
us a little bit more about splunk the
partnership and what you can do thank
you
change so good evening everyone my name
is Mark shinny i'm a product manager for
the IT markets team at splunk and today
goal number one is to make sure that you
all know who splunk is number two if
you're using splunk and you're deploying
on gcp i want to demonstrate the value
that you can get by securing and and
monitoring your services with splunk and
three of course everybody wants to see a
demo so I'll show you but I'll show you
the demo of integrating splunk and
ingesting some of the logs that Joe just
talked about so splunk comes from the
word spelunking which means exploring
underground caves these caves can often
be viewed as all of these sources of
information data machine data that often
go unexplored unless of course there's a
mission-critical problem with your
services or insecurity and all of a
sudden you get all of these stakeholders
your app architects your developers your
security guys all wanting today's logs
yesterday's logs and all the logs to be
able to better troubleshoot the problem
so our mission is funk is simple we want
to make machine data accessible usable
and valuable to everyone let me walk you
through a product portfolio to get a
better understanding of what splunk is
splunk is a platform for operational
intelligence so this means that we can
search analyze monitor and visualize any
unstructured data we're more than just
logs we can monitor mobile performance
metrics we can monitor stream data and
any other type of machine data even oil
rig data and the great thing is as we
offer this on-premise or in the cloud
whether you're just getting started with
10 gigabytes of data per day
or you need to grow to several petabytes
of data per day as some of our largest
customers use plump for today this is
some of something we can accommodate
your needs and most importantly who has
a hunk in their product what a great
name I'm sure Eric would love that name
hunk is their splunk analytics for a
dupe so if you have all these data lakes
and you don't want to obviously change
that data you just want to be able to
search and analyze that data we can also
help you with that we have a rich
ecosystem of applications an add-on that
can collect information from all these
technologies to help you analyze some of
that information these are built by our
partners our customers and ourselves
there's over a thousand limiter and our
App Store our store for all of our
splunk base last we also offer premium
solution that are pre-built for very
specific use case to help your IT
operations and security teams address
very specific needs we're not a start-up
anymore we've been around for over ten
years and we have 11,000 customers where
we've proven the value of splunk of
using splunk to be able to Splunk all
this machine data if you're not on this
list yet I'd love to work with you guys
and make sure that you get on this list
so I'm excited to stand here in front of
you to announce our splunk add-on for
Google cloud platform it's free on
splunk base you can download it today
it'll help you subscribe to any pubsub
events that you have in your mgcp you
can securely access that information
which includes all of the logs exports
that you can define by service and by
source as Joe just talked about
furthermore we've also added the ability
to subscribe to your stack driver
monitoring API so this will give you
access to all the streaming performance
metrics whether its CPU utilization
memory utilization disk i/o for your
cloud sequel services for bigquery
compute engine container engine into
splunk to unify all that data in one
central location so the partnership
between spunk
nGCP was critical for our success in
order to empower our customers you to
get that real-time IT and business
insight and securing the reliability of
your services so without further delay
let me show you a demo come on and you
may have to log me into that laptop Oh
perfect more slide
advanced alright cool
alright so we're going to talk talk
about a very specific scenario here this
is a scenario for Paul he's a level
three support analyst and he was just
about to go for a pee our what are we
were know about 550 but I need to stay
here because you just got a critical
problem that he needs to solve and how
he's going to do this is by using splunk
and her foundation for spunk is are
searching capability everything starts
with a search and we automatically index
content by host source source type and
time it's easy fun to go and it collect
analyze all of this information
essentially from our search interface
very comprehensive search processing
language that allows you to create
statistics apply any arithmetic
operators and several functions to be
able to be able to summarize and analyze
some of that data so in this case we're
looking at JSON objects but any type of
edge structured data we automatically
create fields and categories of
information that's automatically
visualize and analyze by the payloads
that we're looking at so in this case
here you can see all of the information
we've been able to quickly filter by
specific log type and you can also
create Creek visualizations from these
logs that are being collected so here
Paul wants to be able to see how this
data is changing over time so i'll
create a top-end chart be able to see
how my data is doing so here i see a
change by resources that have been
changed using some of the activity logs
that i'm looking at and that can change
all kinds of apply any kinds of rich
visualization to this data i can send
that to a report I can create a new
dashboard or in this case here I'll go
ahead and add it to an existing
dashboard so this is an example
dashboard that summarizes all of my gcp
log events that I have all the data can
be viewed by service by source they can
quickly drill in by specific areas of
interest or how things are trending over
time
all this information is coming from gcp
on top of that Paul has also also has
access to machine learning capability I
can go ahead and take as an example like
my stackdriver cloud monitoring metrics
and go and understand some of the
numeric outliers whether I'm trying to
predict problems understand outliers or
forecasting problems these are all
things that are built in natively in the
platform paul also has access to IT
service intelligence which is an IT
operation tool that gives you a service
aware view of all of the services that
paul is responsible to monitor all the
KPIs are all powered by the searches
that we just talked about and here Paul
could see which kpi's are impacted and
the spunk depot calmness cases
e-commerce site which one is impacted he
also has access to the ITSI glass tables
who has a Visio diagram in their
environment that represents their
ecosystem right or somebody some kind of
a scribble on the whiteboard that you
want to be able to use and be able to
put kpi's on top of that that's what
glass glass table allows you to do all
these services that you have you can
pull these KPIs and the great thing is
you can drill into these KPIs to get
more detailed analysis on the KPIs that
are impacting the services I can move
these swim lanes this is called the ITSI
deep dive this is where Paul in this
case a level three support unless we
spend a lot of time trying to triage
what's going on in his environment and
when the problem happened and what's
that leading indicator that may have
caused a problem in my environment IT
Service intelligence also comes with
modules these modules is just a
normalization of well-known technologies
as an example operating systems load
balancers and others where it normalizes
the data and provides more drill down
capability into specific Diagnostics
views to help you more triage problems
in this case here we're seeing a
degradation you some of the network I
know we always want to blame the network
but in this case here we want to go do a
little bit more assessment to find out
why we're seeing a degradation in the
network utilization one of the questions
that Paul always ask it himself is what
change in my environment by ingesting
the gcp activity
logs I know exactly what change and I'm
also seeing that there's a trend here
that's abnormal or different than what
I'd previously seen by drilling into
these dashboards that I have I'm able to
go and understand what changed who
changed it and when did it change so in
this case here without even the need to
create a war room and engage my DBA my
network guy I can go and talk to this
one person that likely did it change
that was during unplanned work hours you
don't go do changes during a peak
workload so in this case I have all
access to the raw data any
visualizations that we offer and splunk
you can drill down to the actual payload
the unstructured data to further analyze
it and in this case Paul can just pick
up the phone call mark and find out why
he did those changes to the firewall as
a call to action love you guys if you're
not using splunk today it's free it's
available on our website or you can get
it from a SAS you can download it from
our user in a cloud environment or
download it on premise we're at booth 39
if you have any other question and if
you're not using the gcp add-on yet just
launched today please go ahead and give
it a try thank you so much thanks so
much Mark really excited about that
integration now I'd like to introduce
everybody to a town only Yogi and Nitin
now all right from BMC we're going to
tell you a little bit more about vmc and
the integrations with gcp come on up
Thanks show hi I'm Nitin Nohria otoño
neogi will very briefly in the remaining
time available talk about BMC software
and its collaboration with Google in the
context of Google compute cloud to give
you enterprise cloud offering that's
hybrid heterogeneous secure trusted
governed and monitored so if you
typically think of your application
lifecycle this is the general loop
around it and you have the design stage
of building applications and deploy them
and then subsequently scale both for
power
moments and analytics purposes as well
as you monitor for compliance security
and patch in in this particular picture
heterogeneity becomes a recurrent theme
right you want to design it for single
compute instances for multi to your
applications across infrastructure
platform database containers and then
you want to deploy whoever you want you
want to deploy it in your on-premise
data center in Google compute in Google
App engines you want to deploy it in
other public cloud offerings and
subsequently you want to be able to
monitor them scale them as necessary
based on your predefined policies you
are the check for complaints failures
going to check for security intrusions
and subsequently remediate those
failures and intrusions and scale
accordingly based on monitoring data so
for governance and trust you have the
mandatory requirements the industry
compliance regulations the pci-e pie and
all the standard ones but also every
single organization is different right
and they have their organization
specific compliance policies and some of
those compliance policies are automated
and some of those complex policies you
build based on the data that you have
available and applying those compliance
policies finding the failures and find
and remediating them in a manner that's
fully governed by your policies itself
is a significant requirement for all
enterprises so in this google BMC
collaborative partnership we have you
covered as Joe started with the
presentation where the Google cloud fork
platform and BMC you can design your
application workload you can deploy them
in a heterogeneous manner you can scale
them monitor them and you can par from
all aspects of compliance security and
patch for the hybrid cloud and
compliance say cops and patch side BMC
offers cloud lifecycle management which
provides full hybrid cloud solution
across all stacks and subsequently your
workloads can be further scanned for
complaints failures and security
intrusions and patchy shins and
remediated using these server automation
and network or dimensional solutions for
the analytics part I handed over
too yeah so on the monitoring front the
slides are highlighting a couple of BMC
products which are delivered by assass
they are basically true sight pulse and
true site analytics there are more
products which are available on the
monitoring front which you guys can
check out on the BMC side pulse
basically focuses on infrastructure
monitoring and the key value proposition
there is and I'll be demoing it later is
the one second resolution and you would
be able to see that on the analytics to
site analytics front it is focusing on
IT operation analytics you can combine
your business and infrastructure data
sources the data can come from anywhere
it doesn't have to be a BMC product and
that product is going to be released in
April Troost I'd pulse is available
right now so this particular picture
depicts you know it kind of minimized
where a minimalistic way the entire
ecosystem of BM solutions focusing on
the enterprise ops aspects so the BMC
cloud lifecycle management lets you
design and deploy as we will demonstrate
a little later hybrid cloud solutions
across water lords distributed across
the stack of different types of
offerings and different types of cloud
subsequently you can have full scale
server and network automations based on
the design deploy monitor immediate
policies and they offer industry-leading
compliance patch on SE Cupp solutions
and as we talked about you can then
subscribe to the various monitoring and
analytics applications all of these BMC
solutions are connected to the flagship
change management itsm and cmdb
solutions from BMC
so that will switch over to the first
part of our demo which is hybrid cloud
management still the same laptop
next load next slide
just go to the next slide
ok
alright so this is BMC cloud lifecycle
management solution what we're seeing
here is a building of our service
blueprint the blueprint lets you design
your cloud offering once and
subsequently deploy it wherever you want
you know in a policy driven manner and
those policies can be plugged into
different types of automation schemes
including capacity driven placement
charged even placement then answered
even placement so here we are typically
working on a lamp stack and which used
to be deployed on one single particular
vm instance that vm instance is mapped
on to an installable resource or a
particular image which will show that it
is pointing to a Google Cloud image and
once this particular blueprint is
decided to be deployed the deployment is
driven and the last mileage decisions
are made entirely by the policies we
have set up and it could be deployed in
Google compute cloud it could be
deployed in any of the infrastructure
stack you have chosen for your
on-premise environment or any of the
other public cloud offerings here in
this demo will show that once this
blueprint is deployed to the Google
compute cloud how subsequently that
information is absorbed in a normalized
seamless manner in cloud lifecycle
management and further the compliance
and patch actions are done in an
automated manner so the blueprint
designers have a grammar that's embedded
and that's manageable through api's and
has a version control scheme that
composable so it's a full-scale SDDC and
then you show that that particular
blueprint was pointing to this image in
google compute cloud and once this
blueprint was provision or deployed it
led to a Google compute instance that is
that will be further remediated for
compliance failures and you see that the
installable resource which is
highlighted
which is the pointer to the Google
compute instance however it can be
pointed to any particular types of VM
images or container images or other
types of stack that you want your
workloads to run on the blueprint images
the blueprint drummer is is fully public
and control through SJP is and they can
be used as documents looking into the
Google compute instances so this is the
footprint in the Google Cloud and we see
that that's running instance with one
single public IP you can have multiple
IPS based on the policies that we have
set up a blueprint and this is the BMC
cloud lifecycle management where that
particular vm appears and in a manner
that's kind of seamless and transparent
the consumers of your cloud doesn't need
to know where exactly the workload is
running and all the full lifecycle
management of this particular workload
can be performed from the single pane of
glass and BMC offers a set of api's by
which your cloud offerings across all of
the different multiple hybrid clouds can
be managed using single type of api's
with that we'll move on to the next part
of the demo where the cloud lifecycle
management solution where the vm was
deployed can be used to to to check for
compliance valve failures so this is the
server automation switch which does
compliance checks so in this case we see
this for this particular server there
was an automated compliance run for a
particular CVE which had led to this
compliance failure and that compliance
failure was detected the moment the
complaints run was performed and then it
was automatically remediated based on
the policy that you have set up for for
your public cloud offerings and the
remediation job completed successfully
subsequent to that another compliance
run was made to ensure that this
compliance remediation was completed
successfully and it
it did resolve the problem that had
triggered the compliance failure to
begin with this policy or this mechanism
is applied applicable not only to a
custom compliance policies but all types
of industry standards like HIPAA Sox and
they come out of the box the support for
all the industry standard compliances
for custom compliances you can build
custom compliance policies for CVS and
Beyond and any other kind of particular
problems or intrusions you are concerned
about in your public cloud offerings and
they apply seamlessly and transparently
across all of your offerings in public
cloud in all different types of public
cloud as well as your enterprise data
centers with that sure all right so
switch over to the right can you switch
over to my laptop okay all right so what
I'm going to demonstrate here is how you
can use BMC truesight pulse to monitor
vm which has been deployed on on the
Google cloud platform the demo is going
to focus on the vm which is deployed on
google cloud but the pulse can be used
for monitoring your your VMS or any
infrastructure anywhere on prem or cloud
so what you have here is is it BMC
truesight pulse dashboard in terms of
the set of what we have is BMC Google
demo three is a vm which has been
deployed it has been deployed using the
the CLM blueprint and it has been
deployed with the pulse meter which is
essentially an agent which sits on the
vm and there is an engine x server which
is which is also being monitored we also
have a custom plug-in which monitors the
number of connections from a single
client and that's going to be important
for us to for the demo so as you can see
here the dashboard is being updated in
real time you be are tracking the engine
X connection handed CPU inbound network
traffic and the single client
connections Joe here is fiddling with a
spoon looking bored but what he is going
to do is he's going to trigger a denial
of service attack as we speak the
dashboard will update fairly quickly and
you will start seeing a spike in the
engine X connection standard is a live
demo
hopefully everything is working fine in
terms of the network connection and you
should start seeing the spikes so as you
can see here the number of connections
handled by the engine X server has
spiked up you can also see the alarm
bell turning red essentially indicating
that an alarm was triggered you can also
see that the connections have been
initiated from a single client I also
just received an email which basically
shows that the number of connections
have been exceeded and basically we had
threshold set for for this purpose now
if you see over here I can also because
of the custom plug-in I can find out
where the connections are being
initiated from so essentially it is this
IP address 10 for 197 208 and hundred
and thirteen the demo script is
triggered or is supposed to run for
around 20 seconds here so now things are
back not to normal the the alarm
condition has disappeared and I also got
another email indicating that the
problem has been resolved that I'm going
to hand it over to Joe all right thank
you very much guys let's all get fish
back to the sources
right those were just our backup slides
in case we weren't able to do it live so
first of all thank you everyone for
still being here I know if happy hour
starts the moment we walk out of this
room I'm very excited about that and and
so one of the things you might be asking
well you know in the theme of this
conference what is next well happy hours
next but tomorrow you should go to the
Container management talk about Google
container engine and Cooper Nettie's at
eleven o'clock there's also a talk at
two thirty on identity and access
management and I would strongly
encourage you to visit our partners in
their booths both splunk and BMC have
booths out there and they can show you
this more in detail I know they'd be
happy to talk to you we're really
excited about these partnerships and
like I you know said earlier we have
this theme you know we've got you
covered you know we're either going to
do it ourselves or we're going to work
with great partners to help provide the
functionality that you need and with
that thank you very much
you